okay first things first once we've
started to receive this html we'll be
parsing it as we get it
so that's step one
dom construction can be incremental and
the response may not arrive all at once
so we may not finish constructing it all
at once in the head
we'll find links to css and javascript
so then we'll fire off those requests
that's step two but there's a gotcha the
script is synchronous and we can't
execute it until we have the css on so
we'll need to create the css on as soon
as possible
completing the cssom will unblock the
javascript engine so we'll be able to
execute javascript as soon as we've
received it
once the javascript is finished we can
resume and finish constructing the dom
once we have the dom and css on we'll
merge the two and build the render tree
after that we run layout and paint the
page